Bienvenidos a mi presentación del nivel 3
de las ecuaciones...
¿Nivel 3? Sí, sí, sí, del nivel 3 de las ecuaciones lineales.
Y en esta ocasión vamos a poner la siguiente ecuación,
me voy a quedar con "x" más "2x" y a esto le voy a sumar 3, "x" más "2x" más 3 es igual a 7...
no, no, no, mejor "-7x" menos 5...
"-7x" menos 5.
La idea que hay detrás de estas ecuaciones lineales,
es simplificar todo lo que tenga que ver con la variable "x" y todo lo que tenga que ver con los números
para que así nos quede una ecuación del nivel 1 que habíamos visto hace dos presentaciones.
Recuerda que lo que queremos es despejar a "x" y encontrar el valor de "x" que satisfaga esta ecuación.
Así que lo primero que voy a hacer es fijarme
en este lado izquierdo de la ecuación y voy
a simplificar "x" más "2x", es como si tuviera
1 manzana más 2 manzanas, pues son 3 manzanas,
es decir, "x" más "2x" son "3x" más 3,
esto es igual a "-7x" menos 5.
Ahora bien, a continuación lo que voy a hacer
es pasar todo lo que ver con la variable "x"
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación, por lo
tanto para quitar este "-7x" que tengo aquí,
voy a sumar "7x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
de tal manera que "-7x" más "7x" se cancelan.
Recuerda que al sumar "-7x" más "7x" me daría
0 y 0 menos 5 es lo mismo que -5, por lo tanto
estos dos se van.
Y del lado derecho, ¿qué me queda?
"7x" más "3x" es "10x", "10x" más 3 es igual a -5.
Y date cuenta, ya pusimos a todas las "x"
de un lado de la ecuación, del lado izquierdo,
eso es un primer gran paso.
Ahora, lo que quiero que veas
es que ahora tenemos una ecuación del tipo 2, del nivel
2, y por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es restar
-3 de ambos lados de la ecuación para que
se cancele este 3 y yo lo pueda pasar del
otro lado de la ecuación y me quede "10x"
igual a -5 menos 3, que es -8 y así obtenga
una ecuación del nivel 1, del primer video que vimos.
Y por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es dividir
entre 10, para cancelar este 10 que está
al lado de la "x" o en su dado caso multiplicar
por 1/10, recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo
es multiplicando por inverso multiplicativo
de 10, para que así 1/10 por 10 se cancele
y me quede 1 y entonces ya pueda tener a la
"x" despejada del lado izquierdo de la ecuación.
Y entonces ahí va, 1/10 por "10x" es lo mismo
que "x", mientras que del otro lado me queda
-8 sobre 10 y si te das cuenta, -8 sobre 10
lo podemos simplificar un poco,
esto es lo mismo que -4/5, -4 sobre 5.
Y perfecto, ya con esto obtuve el valor de "x".
El valor de "x" que soluciona esta ecuación que tengo arriba es igual a -4/5,
así que vamos a intentar hacer otro ejemplo en donde haya bastantes variables "x"
de ambos lados de la ecuación y además
bastantes constantes.
Así que vamos a poner, "5x" menos 3 menos "7x" esto voy a decir que es igual a se me ocurre, a "x" más 8,
muy bien, ahora es muy buen momento para que tú pares el video e intentes hacerlo por ti mismo,
vayas jugando con estos números y con esta
ecuación a ver si llegas al resultado
y así sirve de paso que haces tus propios experimentos.
Así que voy a asumir que ya paraste el video, porque justo ahorita voy a empezar a resolver esta ecuación.
Porque tengo, "5x" menos "7x", estos dos los puedo reducir de igual manera que en el ejercicio pasado.
Por lo tanto si tengo "5x" menos "7x", es como si tuviera 5 manzanas menos 7 manzanas,
pues entonces debo 2 manzanas, es decir "5x"
menos "7x" es "-2x", "-2x" menos 3 es igual
a "x" más 8 y date cuenta que ese -3 no puedo
operarlo con las "x" porque no tiene "x".
Y bueno, a continuación voy a quitar esta
"x" del lado derecho de igual manera que hice
en el ejercicio pasado restando "x" de ambos
lados de la ecuación, así del lado izquierdo
me queda "-x" menos "2x" lo cual es "-3x",
"-3x" menos 3 y del lado derecho "x" menos
"x", se van, que es justo lo que yo quería
y solamente me queda 8, después voy a quitar
este menos 3, este menos 3 lo voy a quitar
sumando 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
estos 3 se van y me queda simple y sencillamente
"-3x" y del lado derecho me queda 11,
"-3x" igual a 11 y por lo tanto, para acabar este
ejercicio, voy a multiplicar por el inverso
multiplicativo de -3, es cual es -1/3 de ambos
lados de la ecuación y -1/3 por -3 se van
y solamente me queda "x", mientras que del
lado derecho me queda -11/3.
Y bueno, ya tengo la solución de esta ecuación
y de hecho creo que sería bastante bueno
que intentáramos hacer la comprobación de
esta ecuación, así que vamos a hacerlo.
Tengo 5 veces "x", 5 por -11/3,
¿pues cuánto es 5 por -11/3?
Ojo, recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo es sustituyendo el valor de "x" en esta ecuación,
cada vez que yo vea una "x" voy a poner -11/3.
5 por -11/3 es -55/3 y después a esto hay
que quitarle menos 3, pero el -3 lo voy a ver en tercios de una vez, para que todo me
quede en tercios y pueda simplificar en el siguiente paso, entonces en lugar de poner
-3, voy a poner -9/3, todo lo estoy escribiendo con un denominador común y después me queda,
-7 por "x", pero "x" vale -11/3, entonces me va a quedar, menos por menos, más,
7 por 11 = 77, 77/3, muy bien.
Éste salió de -11/3 por -7.
Y del otro lado me queda "x", pero "x" vale
-11/3 y después hay que sumarle 8,
pero recuerda que al 8 lo voy a ver también en tercios
para que todo quede en tercios.
8 es lo mismo que 24/3, muy bien, así es
que vamos a hacer las operaciones de un lado
de la ecuación y del otro lado de la ecuación
para ver si llegamos a una igualdad.
-55 menos 9 es -64, -64/3 más 77/3, según
mis cuentas son 13/3,
es decir, de todo esto son 13/3...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
13/3 del lado izquierdo, vamos a ver si llego
a lo mismo del lado derecho, -11/3 más 24/3,
esto me da...
¡13/3 también, perfecto!
Por lo tanto, la comprobación ya está lista,
acabo de llegar a una igualdad, tanto del
lado derecho como del lado izquierdo llego
a lo mismo y por lo tanto, el valor de "x"
igual a -11/3 hace que se cumpla esta ecuación.
Y aquí ya tienes el nivel 3, el cual era un poco más difícil que el nivel 2 pero lo único que tienes que hacer
es reducir las variables de un lado de la ecuación,
reducir las constantes del otro lado de la ecuación y te va a quedar una ecuación del nivel 1.